what I want to do in this video is
familiarize ourselves with the notion of
a sequence and all sequences is an
ordered list of numbers so for example I
could have a finite sequence that means
I don't have an infinite number of
numbers in it or let's say I start at
one and I keep adding 3 so 1 plus 3 is 4
4 plus 3 7 7 plus 3 is 10 and let's say
I only have these 4 terms right over
here so this one we would call a finite
finite sequence I could also have an
infinite sequence so an example of an
infinite sequence let's say we start at
3 and we keep adding 4 so go to 3 to 7
to 11 15 and you don't always have to
add the same thing we'll explore fancier
sequences 1 the sequence is where you
keep adding the same amount we call
these arithmetic sequences which we will
also explore in more detail but to show
that this is infinite to show that we
keep this pattern going on and on and on
I'll put three dots this just means
we're going to keep going on and on and
on so we could call this an infinite
infinite sequence now there's a bunch of
different notations that seem fancy for
denoting sequences but this is all they
refer to but I want to make us
comfortable with how we can denote
sequences and also how we can define
them so we could say we could say that
this right over here is the sequence a
sub K a sub K for K is going from 1 to 4
is equal to this right over here so when
we look at it this way we can look at
each of these as the terms in the
sequence and this right over here would
be the first term we would call that a
sub 1 this right over here would be the
second term we call it a sub 2 I think
you get the picture a sub 3 this right
over here is a sub 4 so this just says
all of the a sub KS from K equals 1 from
our first term all the way to the fourth
term now I could also define it by not
putting explicitly writing the sequence
like this I could essentially do it
using defining our sequence as
explicitly using a kind of a function
notation or something close to function
notation so the same exact the same
exact sequence
I could define it as a sub K from K
equals 1 to 4 with with instead of
explicitly writing the numbers here I
could say a sub K is equal to some
function of K so let's see what happens
when K is 1 we get 1 when K is 2 we get
4 when K is 3 we get 7 so let's see when
K is 3 we added 3 twice let me make it
clear so this was plus 3 this right over
here was a plus 3 this right over here
is a plus 3 so whatever K is we added we
started at 1 and we added 3 1 less than
the K term times so we could say that
this is going to be equal to 1 1 plus 1
plus K minus 1 1 plus K minus 1 times 3
or maybe Baxter right 3 times K minus 1
same thing 3 times K minus 1 and you can
verify that this works so you can verify
that this works if K is equal to if K is
equal to 1 you're going to get 1 minus 1
is 0
and so a sub 1 is going to be 1 if K is
equal to 2 you can have 1 plus 3 which
is 4 if K is equal to 3 you get 3 times
2 plus 1 is 7 so it works out so this is
what this is one way to explicitly
define our sequence with kind of this
function notation I want to make clear
I've essentially defined a function here
if I wanted in more traditional function
notation I could have written a of K
where K is the term that I care about a
of K is equal to 1 plus 3 times K minus
1 this is essentially a function where
an allowable input the domain is
restricted to two positive integers now
how would I denote this business right
over here well I could say that this is
equal to this is equal to and people
tend to use a but you could I could use
the notation B sub K or anything else
but I'll do a again a sub K and here
we're going from K from our first term
so this is a sub 1
one this is a sub to all the way to
infinity or we can define if we wanted
to define it explicitly as a function we
could write this sequence as a sub K
where K starts at the first term and
goes to infinity with with a sub K is
equally so we're starting at three we're
starting at three and we are adding four
we're adding four one less time for the
second term we added four once for the
third term we add four twice for the
fourth term we add four three times so
we're adding four one less than the term
that we're at so it's going to be plus
four times four times K minus one four
times K minus one so this is another way
of defining this infinite sequence now
in both of these cases I defined it as
an explicit function so this right over
here is explicit let me that's not
enough that's not an attractive color
let me write this in these are this is
an explicit function and so you might
say well what's what's another way of
defining these functions well we can
also define it especially something like
this Erath we could all like an
arithmetic sequence we can also define
it recursively and I want to be clear
not every sequence can be defined as
either an explicit function like this or
as a recursive function but many can
including this which is an arithmetic
sequence where we keep adding the same
quantity over and over again so how
would we do that well we could also
another way of defining this first
sequence we could say a sub K starting
at K equals 1 and going to 4 with and
when you define things recursively when
you define a sequence recursively you
want to define what your first term is
with a sub 1 a sub 1 equaling 1 and then
you can define you can find every other
term in terms of the term before it and
so that we could write a a of K plus or
let me write it this way a sub K a sub K
is equal to the previous term is equal
to the previous term so this is a sub K
minus 1 so a given term is equal to the
pre
via Sturm let me make it clear this is
the previous the previous term plus the
previous term plus in this case we're
adding three every time we're adding
three every time now how does this make
sense well we're defining what a sub one
is and if someone says well what happens
when K equals two well they're saying
well it's going to be a sub two minus
one so it's going to be a sub one plus
three well we know a sub 1 is 1 so it's
going to be one plus three which is four
well what about a sub 3 what's going to
be a sub 2 plus 3 a sub 2 we just
calculated is 4 you add 3 is going to be
7 this is essentially what we mentally
did when I first wrote out the sequence
when I said hey I'm just going to start
with 1 I'm just going to start with 1
and I'm just going to add 3 for every
successive term so how would we do this
one well once again we could write this
as a sub K starting at K the first term
going to infinity with our first term a
sub 1 is going to be 3 now and every
successive term a sub K is going to be
the previous term the previous term a
sub K minus 1 plus 4 plus 4 and once
again you start at 3 and then if you
want the second term it's going to be
the first term plus 4 it's going to be 3
plus 4 you get to 7 and you keep adding
4 so both of these this right over here
is a recursive definition recursive we
started with kind of a base case and
then every term is defined in terms of
the term before it or in terms of the
function itself with the function for a
different term